[Music]
all right welcome to hannity a lot of
breaking news tonight the 2020
presidential election is officially
gearing up
and the democratic party they're
imploding radical extreme
far-left socialists have now taken over
any
and any democrat who doesn't fall in
line and support this radical extreme
agenda
this left-wing vision if you will you
get thrown down the curb by
ocasio-cortez
you have a group now and all of america
needs to see this
hyperpartisan freshman lawmakers they
are now leading the way
they set the agenda nancy pelosi is
afraid of all of those freshmen
a list is led by alexandria
ocasio-cortez now according to a report
from the washington post
she warned her fellow democratic
lawmakers
not to vote with republicans or she's
going to put them on a list
to be primaried in the next election
welcome to congress
now no surprise there political
intimidation is always a key component
of socialism
now after all she needs as much support
as she can get
for this insane green new deal which
vows to totally reshape america
by putting an end to all fossil fuels
combustion
engines nuclear energy airplanes and yes
cows because of flatulence and co2 gases
it also promises to provide everything
is free
you don't have to worry another day in
your life free government healthy food
free day care for your kids
free housing free college education
forget about k
through 12. free universal health care
free free
oh but pro-choice democrats they're
going to allow you to have your private
plan anymore
forget choice you get guaranteed
vacations you get
universal guaranteed income a guaranteed
retirement
even people unwilling to work but like
any other socialist ocasio-cortez
she's really just interested in
improving her own quality of life and
redistributing the wealth
among those in her own inner circle look
at this according to a
brand new bombshell fec complaint
ocasio-cortez's chief of staff
is now accused of illegally moving
nearly a million dollars in campaign
contributions
to his own private companies and in
doing so
all that money could be shielded from
all election related reporting
in other words ocasio-cortez under fire
tonight her chief of staff
could have used those donations for
anything without reporting it
including maybe big payments to
themselves
their family their friends we already
know based on a separate fec complaint
that ocasio-cortez's boyfriend well he
was funneled thousands of dollars from a
political action committee
set up by this very same chief of staff
but really
who can blame him for taking the money
after all it's incredibly expensive to
keep
up with the jet-setting lifestyle of the
freshman socialist congresswoman
last night we first showed you how
ocasio-cortez
who wants to ban all air travel
but she herself loves flying on
airplanes between new york and d.c
now there's something called amtrak it
goes pretty much every hour on the hour
between dc and new york and she chooses
not to do that in fact
she chooses to take a plane three times
more
when three times more travelers
themselves choose amtrak
between the two cities not ocasio-cortez
she prefers the convenience of flying
especially since you
we the american people will be picking
up the bill cost more to fly
now fox news producer caught up with
ocasio-cortez as she was getting off a
flight in d.c today
we asked her about her travel
preferences recent fec
complaints and much more take a
and then um what look the difference
between you taking a flight train excuse
me sir
um a couple hours of my constituents
time
thing all right and then also do you
have any comment on the fec violation
uh filed against your office there is no
violation
so there's no violation do you think
that's a sign of you taking the dark
money
oh no no
well she's learned how to duck questions
pretty quickly now i thought the world
was going to end in 12 years if we
didn't
make all these drastic sacrifices and
changes right now
that's right socialists it's always do
as i say not as i do
now that's why she has no problem taking
planes over trains why she prefers that
caravan the gas guzzler
and that service over public
transportation it's why ocasio-cortez
probably doesn't want you to know
that her very own mother left the great
state of new york because of its
incredibly high taxes
it's why bernie and hillary and joe
biden and al gore they all take private
jets and we catch them all the time
and get this even though a climate
change apocalypse is on the horizon
recycling well that's just way too much
work
than ocasio-cortez is willing to put in
the hypocrisy is just rampant take a
look
i can be upset that i get 10
plastic bags at the grocery store and
then
have to toss out my plastic bags because
the recycling program in the area is
tough and that's okay
oh that's okay if she thinks recycling
plastic bags is tough
how does she expect you the american
people you have to rebuild
all of your houses within 10 years
you're going to get rid of your gas
powered cars
you're going to have to stop eating red
meat and flying in airplanes
remember ocasio-cortez fought hard to
block
amazon from building their headquarters
in new york city
that would have been 30 40 50 000 jobs
for new yorkers
why because of their evil capitalist
ways
well now after so much bad press she is
backtracking her chief of staff is
reportedly saying that amazon's 25
000 jobs might be welcomed in the city
probably too late
under the right conditions how generous
and keep in mind socialism
that's only one component of what is now
this
radical extreme democratic socialist
party and their agenda
in fact as we were pointing out last
night many of the same far-left
lawmakers
pushing socialist policies are also
spreading vile
hateful rabid anti-semitic views
all throughout the halls of congress
look at minnesota congresswoman woman
omar
once again facing more backlash after
yet another
anti-semitic comment on twitter first
she proclaimed that
israel was evil and hypnotizing the
world
then she suggested the support for
israel was just because of
jewish money or as she put it all about
the benjamins
and most recently she pushed a longtime
anti-semitic
conspiracy theory that her colleagues
support israel
because they have a dual allegiance to
the country
now for the second time the house of
representatives has been forced to pass
a resolution
reminding some democrats that
anti-semitism
is bad and will not be tolerated well
that's not stopping congresswoman cortez
from defending her anti-semitic
colleague on twitter
writing quote now if we called
resolutions
on sexist statements a good chunk of
congress would be gone
to jump to the nuclear option every
single time
you know leaves the room and for some
correction of action
i'm asking everybody that we practice
calling
in before calling out so i guess
socialists
you know sort of a feather stick
together right
birds of a feather even when one of them
is absolutely obsessed with hating
the world's only jewish state our
closest ally
in the region the only democracy in the
region
israel and meanwhile far left
anti-semitic bigot and self-proclaimed
women's rights leader
linda sarsour backing up her radical
friends on capitol hill
slamming speaker pelosi's decision to
put forth the resolution
against anti-semitism calling the
speaker quote
a typical white feminist upholding the
patriarchy doing
the work of power white men wow
and you know what nancy pelosi is afraid
to take a stand because that freshman
group
they can unseat her pretty quickly so
while some congressional democrats focus
on
hating israel and a bizarre socialist
eco state
well congresswoman maxine waters is back
and she's sticking to her
own longtime favorite obsession
impeaching 45
and yesterday she renewed these new
fantasies on twitter writing that quote
impeachment is the only answer socialism
anti-semitism
impeachment unprecedented 24 7 365
investigations eight committees into all
things donald trump
an investigation in search of a crime
any crime
24 7 abuse of power try to bloody
bludgeon the president politically
impeach him if they can't impeach him
death by a thousand cuts
it is a very scary picture inside this
new radical democratic party
and as the 2020 primary season kicks
into high gear it has become
very clear that it will be a contest to
see who can present
the single most radical most extreme
most socialist vision for america's
future
do you want america to be a socialist
country
bernie sanders appears to have some
early momentum on the fence candidates
like crazy uncle joe biden
he may be losing before he even starts
look at what happened during fake news
cnn's democratic focus group
earlier today i hope uncle joe's
watching take a look
how many of you would like to see joe
biden get in show of hands
what's happening his time is done
but to be honest you know senator biden
really comes from
the kind of the good old boy politics of
the past
i don't think joe biden represents that
new thing that we need
we just we need a new economy we need a
new politics and
we need someone different remember if
hillary didn't cheat
that nomination would have gone to
bernie sanders and while biden is on the
fence deciding whether or not he's going
to run
hillary wow huge announcement she won't
try it a third time
and that's not stopping her allies from
rehashing old wounds from with sanders
from 2016.
this intramural democratic battle is
real remember last week former clinton
aide referred to sanders as quote
his royal majesty king bernie sanders
well he doesn't have four mansions
we do know that apparently he demands
private jet rides while campaigning for
clinton apparently they didn't like that
that's prompting a former sanders
campaign ad to call the clinton camp
quote
some of the biggest a-holes in american
politics
so does showing no signs of stopping and
as clinton allies are continuing to
snipe at sanders
well with one former adviser recently
tweeting that only half of bernie's
donors will quote
named vladimir wow not even president
now even president trump weighing in
he's getting in on the fund crook and
hillary clinton confirmed she will not
run in 2020.
rules out a third bid for the white
house ah shucks
does that mean i won't get to run
against her again she will be sorely
missed and even without hillary clinton
2020
is shaping up to be a very very toxic
year for the democrats
now their issues are much larger than
any of this infighting
this is where it gets serious the
democrats biggest problem is
they are pushing the most radical agenda
of any party in this country's history
by the way before birth up to birth
during birth after birth abortions that
is called infanticide
that is a child living alone outside the
womb that would be called murder
that's the party of the democrats now
the party telling you it might be
reckless to have kids like ocasio-cortez
the party that wants to take away
all private health care insurance they
want to socialize
nationalize health care now they're
talking about legalizing drugs and
prostitution
that's gaining momentum among the 2020
candidates
reparations is now backed by many
candidates like kamala harris elizabeth
warren
many are supporting this top marginal
tax rate 70 percent
and by the way after you pay your 70 and
get to keep maybe 30
maybe not depending what state you live
in well if you save some
money then elizabeth warren wants a
wealth tax on top of it
she wants another bite of the apple and
then by the way when you die in the
united states of america you got to pay
to die
if you have any money left in your bank
account guess what they're going to take
40
of that and if you live in new york
they'll take another 10 and by the way
so they can take care of people that are
unwilling to work
and of course pay for child care and
retirement and
government food and health care and
college
they're going to eliminate fossil fuels
gas and oil they're going to destroy the
lifeblood of our economy
they're going to get rid of planes
mandate you rebuild your home
who's paying for that the estimates now
are as high as 94 trillion dollars in 10
years
that's their proposal pushing open
borders
remember bozo o'rourke actually wants to
tear down the border walls
preventing any of us from being safe and
secure that would leave all of us
defenseless against
cartels and drug traffickers and human
traffickers of young women into
prostitution
gangs that make this country totally
defenseless
the 90 percent of heroin that comes
through our southern border
now it gets through even more easily and
don't forget
free everything health care college
child care vacations
free healthy government food it's a
party that is totally fueled by a desire
to run your life
take your hard-earned money give it to
someone else
and use it to buy power and votes for
themselves
as they live the lap of luxury a party
committed to destroying
the single greatest best economic system
that has led more people out of poverty
that has created
more wealth and prosperity that has
created more opportunity
than any other economic system in the
history of man
a democratic party with no plan to make
your life better
more safe more secure more prosperous
for not only you
but for your children and your
grandchildren they are fueled too
by a rage a hate and obsession with
victimhood and identity politics
entitlement pushing doom and gloom day
and night
climate hysteria indoctrinating your
kids into believing the world is ending
in 12 years
just to push the socialist agenda a
party fueled by what
is can only be described as psychotic
literally unhinged rage and hatred
every second minute hour of every day
against the duly elected president
and they're not even trying to hide it
just today we learned that
shifty adam schiff hired former msnbc
legal analyst collusion conspiracy
theorist
daniel goldman to lead this new witch
hunt against the president and the house
intel committee forget the mueller
report that's not working out the way we
want we'll rewrite it
and as the daily caller points out
goldman has already been caught
asserting baseless russia hysteria look
at the screen
he was promoting the phony steel dossier
the debunked steel dossier even
debunked by michael cohen who never went
to prague
and there were no hookers urinating in
donald trump's bed
in moscow they weren't there now we have
more evidence endless fishing
expeditions have nothing to do with the
truth
everything to do with making every
working day a public trial against the
president
look at this even david axelrod has more
sense than this
former chief strategist for obama
agreeing writing on twitter
that the democrats wide-ranging
investigations
too easily play into the witch-hunt meme
look at that he's right and that's
because the democrats are engaging
in a witch-hunt all right here with
reaction as
we now are looking at two very distinct
paths
for the future